hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
the tale of Apple's humble beginnings is
one that most technology enthusiasts
would be familiar with it's a classic in
April 1976 21 year old Steve Jobs and 26
year old Steve Wozniak began building
their technological Empire from the
garage of Steve Jobs's parents home
Steve Wozniak had the technology skills
and Steve Jobs was the one who knew how
to sell them it was a match made in
heaven and what they created together
has now grown into a two trillion dollar
company it's an inspirational Tale of
Two Friends succeeding against the odds
but what most people don't know is that
there was a third player in those early
days
while jobs in Wozniak can be credited
for the overall success of the company
the die-hard Apple historians consider
this third founder an essential part of
the story
his name was Ronald Gerald Wayne the
lesser-known co-founder of the Apple
computer company
here's a living example of the
cautionary tale about letting your past
failures blind you from success for
Ronald this would be a multi-billion
dollar lesson
you are watching confusion TV
[Music]
born in Cleveland Ohio Ronald Wayne had
a relatively unremarkable childhood but
he was always a curious child and really
wanted to understand how things worked
in 1953 he graduated from the school of
industrial Arts in New York after this
he wouldn't bark on a journey of
self-education in electrical mechanical
engineering and product development
at age 22 he would move west looking for
opportunity
Ronald worked various jobs throughout
his 20s and early 30s and in 1971 he
would start his own business
for nearly five years Wayne operated an
engineering firm named cyan that was
based out of Las Vegas and fittingly
specialized in slot machines sadly this
business would eventually fail
now Wayne was a gifted engineer but
running a business wasn't something that
he excelled at he told Cult of Mac in
2014 quote I discovered very quickly
that I had no business being in business
I was far better working in engineering
in an uncharacteristic act for most
businessmen Ronald Wayne spent the
entire year following the business
collapse paying back everyone who had
invested in his company
he personally felt responsible for their
losses he bought all the shares back at
exactly the price the investors paid for
them feeling compelled to make things
right with everyone who had put faith in
him
the failure of his business was a deeply
traumatic experience for Wayne and
shaped his tendency to avoid risk moving
forward a key part to the story
later on accepting that running a
business wasn't for him Wayne landed a
job as Chief draftsman at the newly
found Atari video game company and this
was where he met a man named Steve Jobs
and his friend Steve Wozniak
the first time that Wayne was approached
about a possible business opportunity by
jobs it didn't go well
despite knowing about Wayne's previous
failures in the slot machine industry
jobs was eager to partner up after
coming into some money
Steve Jobs told Wayne that he had access
to fifty thousand dollars and asked him
if he was interested in getting back
into the slot machine business
Wayne would say that that would be the
quickest way for him to lose fifty
thousand dollars
now Wayne was not particularly fond of
jobs as were most that worked with him
Wayne even went so far as to say that if
he had the choice between Steve Jobs and
an ice cube you would nuzzle up to the
Ice Cube for warmth
but he did recognize the then 21 year
old's passion and drive so when the
offer for the next business venture came
Wayne wasn't so quick to turn it down
in 1976 Wayne invited jobs and Wozniak
to his home it was going to be a night
of a very heated debate about computer
design according to Wayne these debates
were a regular occurrence but this night
was different
as the night wore on their discussions
became passionate and they all began
down a path of unlimited possibility
remember at this point the CPU
microprocessor was only a few years old
personal computers weren't officially a
thing only DIY hobbyist kits existed
after hours of debate Steve Jobs
proposed that the three of them should
start their own company with the two
Steves at the helm and Wayne as a lesser
owner
from the beginning jobs and Wozniak were
clear that this was going to be
predominantly their company a decision
that Wayne did not oppose given his
experience after owning a business
the structure was pitched like this jobs
and Wozniak would hold a 45 stake each
leaving 10 for Wayne he would act as a
tiebreaker on decisions where the two
Steves couldn't agree
Ronald Wayne who was 41 at the time
would act as the adult in the room to
reign in the two highly ambitious
headstrong 21 and 25 year old Steves
Wayne agreed and on April 1st 1976 the
Apple computer company was born
during his early days with Atari Wayne
built the internal corporate document
systems using those skills he got to
work on the Apple partnership agreement
outlining each Founder's role within the
startup
Steve Jobs would be responsible for
electrical engineering and marketing
Wozniak would oversee electrical
engineering and Wayne would oversee
mechanical engineering and documentation
once this was settled Steve Jobs would
sell his VW Microbus for a few hundred
dollars and Wozniak would sell his HP
calculator for 500 and with the money
they got to work building their first
prototype of the Apple One a computer
kit that allowed hobbyists to Tinker
with the new and wonderful world of PCS
Wayne was responsible for writing the
manual for the apple one and he also
designed Apple's first logo a Victorian
woodcut style image of Isaac Newton
sitting beneath an apple tree around the
Border read the quote a mind forever
wondering through strange Seas of
thought alone it was from William
wordsworth's piece the Prelude this logo
would be replaced a year later by the
multi-colored two-dimensional apple
design which would become iconic in time
everything was now in place for this
exciting startup the paperwork was
complete the Prototype was ready and
fifteen thousand dollars in funding had
been secured to buy materials the first
unit produced was used in a high school
math class about 200 units were produced
and basically all of them sold within 10
months
very soon after jobs sold about 50
computers to The Bike Shop computer
store at about 500 each
it was now full steam ahead for Apple
computer
but just 12 days after signing the
agreement Wayne had resigned he sold his
share of the company back to the two
Steves for eight hundred dollars
now that Apple has become a global
success story it's easy to question
Wayne's thought process but at the time
Apple was just one of many startups
forming in residential basements and
garages
it's estimated that 20 percent of small
businesses fail within the first year 50
within the first five years and 65
percent within the first 10 years
with the gift of hindsight we all know
that Apple was a safe bet but to Wayne
this was a big gamble and a gamble that
he had lost before
the two Steves were still young there
was little to lose in terms of assets if
things went poorly
as a part of the partnership agreement
all parties involved would be
responsible for any debt incurred by
individual members
Wayne understood the risks he had
experienced what it was like to run a
business from the ground first hand and
he knew that the store who had placed
the initial orders of the Apple One the
bite shop was notoriously loose with
payment schedules
Wayne was very spooked by how fast
things were moving the anxiety from his
previous business failure got the better
of him the decision to resign will
likely go down in history as one of the
biggest missed opportunities ever made
in business
did you have any doubt that Apple would
be a successful company none I was it
was the right product at the right time
so why did you sell out my passion
wasn't uh computers in the first place
it was slot machines I also knew
that I was standing in the shadow of
giants
and as a result I knew I was never going
to have
a product of my own to develop so with
that being said I bet you're all
wondering just how much money did Ronald
Wayne miss out on
exactly how much his 10 share in apple
would be worth today is entirely
speculative
but today a 10 share in apple would be
worth
229 billion dollars
but it's likely that over that time his
shares would have been diluted there
would have been many decisions made over
the decades that make it impossible to
predict exactly how much Wayne would be
worth today
but given Apple's current 2.3 trillion
dollar market cap it's safe to say that
Wayne would comfortably be a
multi-millionaire perhaps even a
billionaire had he held on to even a
fraction of his share
following his departure from Apple Wayne
continued to work various roles
throughout California
he stayed with Atari until 1978. after
this point he would then leave and work
for Lawrence Livermore National
Laboratory and later for a small
electronics firm called ldf
semiconductors Apple went public in 1980
and Wayne had moved on
not long after Wayne decided to pursue
his other passion and opened a collector
store dealing in stamps and coins
for a time his store was quite
successful but following the collapse of
the stamp market and two break-ins he
was forced to close the shop and operate
the business from home sadly in another
cruel twist of fate Ronald Wayne would
lose his life savings during a home
robbery he had retired and moved to
Florida with 145 ounces of gold and
three thousand dollars worth of silver
to his name sadly after the robbery his
savings were never recovered and he was
forced to sell his home to recoup the
losses
Ronald Wayne is now living in a mobile
home park in Nevada where he still
collects stamps rare coins and other
artifacts
in the early 2010s he published two
books one was Adventures of an apple
co-founder a memoir about his brush with
Fame and Fortune and the other insolence
of office an in-depth look at the
origins Evolution and nature of money
and is currently in the process of
crowdfunding a third book titled
counterfeit trust and the nature of
money a further investigation into
Global monetary systems
although he would never work at Apple
again Ronald Wayne did keep in touch
with the two Steves
both Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak would
speak exceptionally high of Wayne and
regularly praised him in interviews for
being kind intelligent and a gracious
man and those qualities can be seen in
how Wayne conducted himself since
leaving Apple
surprisingly Wayne regularly states that
he does not regret the decision to leave
the company and he stands by his
cautious approach in his mind he made
the best decision with the information
available to him and his happy to live
with that choice
you must often think of what could have
been yeah with apple I mean do you I
knew exactly what would have been if I
had a state with the company uh I would
have wound up heading a very large
documentation department at the back of
the building shuffling papers for the
next 20 years of my life and that was
not the future that I saw for myself
Ronald Wayne does have one regret though
in the early 90s he sold his original
copy of his Apple contract for five
hundred dollars
at the time this seemed like a good deal
as he could have never predicted just
how passionate Apple memorabilia
collectors would become
he said that the contract had been
sitting in a filing cabinet collecting
dust and he couldn't understand why he
would need to hold on to it fifteen
years later the same contract sold at an
auction for 1.59 million dollars
after hearing the news of the sale
Ronald Wayne said quote
in that you have the Story of My Life
and that ends the story of Ronald G
Wayne the guy who was there at the
beginning of one of the most successful
companies in history but decided to turn
away how do you think you would feel if
you're in his situation it's interesting
to think about
if you want to see more Apple history I
have a documentary about the team that
created the iPhone it's a wild tale of
unfair treatment behind the scenes
stories and a workplace pressure so vast
that it ruined marriages this episode
has an exclusive interview with one of
the original iPhone's key team members
so this is definitely worth checking out
if you haven't seen it already
and lastly for those of you who follow
my music I have a new album out now if
you want to listen to it I'll leave a
link below
anyways thanks for watching my name is
Togo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
it's new thinking